former agency operative rico rodriguez
up to this point his whereabouts have
been unknown since our withdrawal from
medici
responsible for deposing half a dozen
heads of state
the black hand have encountered them
before in san esperito
where he assassinated our employer
president salvador mendoza
we fought him again in medicine where he
overthrew sebastiano di rabello
though the agency had some involvement
this is his handler tom sheldon
we've learned rodriguez's motivation for
liberating medici was personal
you have briefed me on this man before
commander morales
we're preparing a test can we cut to the
chase por favor of course nurse pinosa
intelligence suggests that he is the son
of miguel rodriguez
miguel rodriguez
and
and he's here
in solis
now
this
so
that's my father's super weapon
project
he was a kind man my father
a scientist
doesn't make sense he would build such a
thing my uncle was a good man too
and they both ended up dead
lots of questions
time to get some answers
you can't do this alone
i have people who can help us here i've
done this kind of thing before this is
different i can handle some bad weather
it's more than bad weather rico if you
would just listen to me
a plan is a list of things that go wrong
i like to keep my legs short
just be ready
when i patch you into that console
you'll have to find espinoza quickly he
answers my questions we destroy project
yappa
plan
where
hear you loud and clear
i'm going to monitor your progress from
a safe distance
the road is walled off
can you get over it
okay where to now
those lights across the valley head
towards them
gonna jump
that's a big tower
espinosa promises it will change the
world no more tornadoes or hurricanes
and most of solis
won't be a problem after today mira
if your plan works
it will work
we've come face to face before heading
up
uh
[Music]
we're sending a unit now
weren't too happy to have me poking
around
they black hand are highly trained mercs
and they're wholly owned by espinosa
his own private army
pretty good one too
i see those outcroppings
you're on the right track can you get
across
no swift
foreign
in
[Music]
i'll figure it out
uh
hmm could use this vent to get me up
want to be out there when that case
starts
almost there
no further contact our units
taking this
oh
ah
okay mira i found the console
and i'll locate espinosa for you
you're
stay close to that console or i'll lose
my connections
[Music]
well [ __ ]
[Music]
they're trying lady
grateful of
well they weapons hand never deploy
unprepared
[Music]
a lot of black hand here
i'm through security
just hang in a few more seconds and
you'll be able to move ricco i'm looking
for him
take your time
[Music]
[Music]
all that and he's at the top of the
he's unlikely he has survived this long
this is not an ordinary man's norse
pinosa
we might as well make sure
let's see what project yappa can do
shall we
take a few moments for the court to
reach full power
do you think you can keep him occupied
until then
this is commander morales we have a
threat on site
activate yappa's defenses engage all
artillery towers
that woman with rico at the airport
is that who i think it was
see
deal with that please
with pleasure
please respond
i lost your gps see my grappling looks
broken
as well as my wingsuit
parachute
maybe a few ribs
i'll need to make repairs
what's your location
hey forest
i don't know
i'm sending you my coordinates
i hope it works
got it i'll see you soon
[ __ ]
ah not having my grappling hook is like
missing a limb
back to your posts target is gone
hmm
hey sonova
ah
not having my grappling hook is like
missing a limb
why do you have to be like that man
that looks like the place
never seen anything like yappa before
mira might be right
people here must not be afraid of
heights
i know you're not
i'm not but i usually have a parachute
um
you see that storm last night
yeah fine
black hand chopper
that's not good
empty it out fast
here are trying to get away from
espinosa in his black hands
you look awful
agua
the black hand are casing the village
does that happen often
almost never
maybe somebody attacked their weather
base
tools
gracias
i don't think i could take project
diaper alone i agree
i'm saying i was wrong
you were right
is that a distress signal
i didn't think you are with the agency
anymore
help me with this
what do we do about yappa
between the blizzard and those artillery
towers i can't get close
i have a couple of ideas
tell me
wait
listen
your actions in the next few minutes may
determine the fate of this community
i am commander morales
i have tolerated a lapisma for years
to maintain order and justice in solis
i've allowed this place to serve as a
refuge for the criminal and the
disenfranchised
but last night a terrorist attack was
launched against the project diaper
facility
the culprit was abetted by a conspirator
from this village
who is that
gabriela
she killed my uncle when i was a girl
she knows we're working together
if mira morales is not surrendered to me
immediately
i'll be forced to conduct an exhaustive
investigation
every home will be searched every
citizen's identity will be checked
and all transgressions will be harshly
prosecuted
you
luis
where is mira
where
i have to stop this
gabriella
let him go cussing
at least you aren't a coward
your father would be disgusted with the
monster you've become you two traitors
can discuss your disappointment together
in prison
load into my chopper
i freeze
we need
i think we just started our rebellion
we didn't have to drag these people into
this they are what we need to put down
project diaper
well they'll need more guns yes so
there's a factory down the road from
here abandoned
we used to manufacture black hand
weapons years ago
let's check it out
luis right
organize these people anyone who wants
to fight the black hand gets to fight
show for it
mira
i need to make sure my gear is working
i'll meet you at the factory
hope
everything works
ah perfect
rico it's luis uh i mean it's argento
they can help you get this place up and
running
who's is he
hola i'm the hacker
hi
that's what you've got your ar lens
mirror told me already done
you have an ar lens like a little
computer on your eyeball
something like that let's get started
you're up
here's your mission the factory needs to
be powered on but the doors to the
electrical room are being held shut by
backup generators
mission accepted sorry
it's only a matter of time before
gabriela sends more black hand to stop
us
we need to get these people gone fast
that worked
generators well shielded
can you turn it off
i think i can use my grappling hook to
rip the plating off
and now i guess i shoot it in the guts
one generator down
yeah
okay two more to go you know where to
look
oh
uh
just
oh
[Applause]
excuse me
uh
i'll handle it
leaving my back
hmm
two down one to go
here's the last one
ugh
generators are all off
and the doors just opened
choppers and troops hated this way rico
better wake this place up or we'll be
fighting them off with sticks and stones
[Applause]
i'll handle them
i'll handle them
i'm heading in
find the breakers and flip them
hmm
need to use my grappling hook
here's the other one
breakers are on
and the black hand are almost here
just hit the master override
we're in business let's call everyone in
just give the order
you got us those guns just in time they
black hand are deploying their forces
across the river we won't be able to
advance the line without more fighters
any ideas
we became soldiers after what you did in
the slums create more chaos more
recruits will come whole army of chaos
this is what you wanted from the start
oscar espinosa owns this island the
people can't fight him without losing
their jobs their homes
and even if they tried what chance would
they have against a black hand
we have a mutual goal rico
you help these people defeat their black
hand
and we'll help you get to oscar espinosa
okay mira
we'll do it your way
what's first
i got some ideas rico
i will rated your eyeball with more
information
a whole army of chaos
sure
army of chaos
you